I was there I was doing a movie in
Thailand we was actual triple threat
comes out next next this year March is
another Crotty movie that you were in
what movies have you been in just
rattled me up to a few but not too many
martial art movies like that so no
fighting movies not too many no okay not
too many now I think want back in the
day long long long time ago called
beatdown I'll be sure yeah this one's
called triple threat who's in it Tony
Jaa ego weighs target chained me Michel
Jarre white Scott Adkins wow it's the
best martial arts can get right now
movies gonna be sick just me was there a
lot of like coordination and of course
yes [ __ ] martial arts me what do you
think just winged it we did off the top
of her head what do you reckon I don't
know just go for it and maybe I'll look
good yes there was coordination it was
highly choreographed okay just stop
there go save your thing I just got to
defend myself real quick okay all right
I'm just saying that there's different
kinds right there's like you know John
I'm John weeks pretty coordinated but
anyway right you're a movie
it's a [ __ ] there's a lot of people
down it's a bad movie it's like millions
and millions and millions of dollars
they plot it out okay
alright my god no so anyway so when the
dog died when my German Shepherd that my
best friend in the whole world yeah so
it was the first it was the last day on
set but it was the first scene in the
movie that you'll see me right and we go
into this village in Thailand me and
material the bad guys and [ __ ] cute
everyone blow the village job typical
[ __ ] something like out of Rambo
whatever anyway we're rescuing my
brother and he's in like this makeshift
cell if you will in the ground and
anyway
break you know you know whatever cut and
we have a little time you know with the
setting of the next shot so I get my
phone out and I look at my phone and
I've got a text message from my wife
call me ASAP detail not good I'm like
[ __ ] so I call and say yeah
in a really bad way we've tape we're at
the vets right now the vet says you know
we've got to put him down
Oh what the [ __ ] so I get on the phone
to the vet and the vet tells me it
explains all the problems so we had to
put him down it was furry song so anyway
so I'm we were filming by the River Kwai
in Thailand right and the [ __ ] eyes
out right and I'm like I'm walking off
more and more into the forest you know
I'd like to be left alone about half an
hour passes in that the little one is
that oh my god my god director say but
whether if I or you know I'm [ __ ]
crying and stuff and anyway so your
Asian accent is dead-on sounded like it
that's what he sounded like
but that's what he sounded like my god
so so I go back [ __ ] I'm gonna be a
badass in this scene I've just been
bawling my eyes out right do the scene
it was a bit [ __ ] in my opinion because
I've been crying anyway we sit down and
I'm not in the next shot so we're
sitting down and they got this big fan
going because he's very humid in
Thailand I'm Michel Jarre white stare do
you know Michel Jarre white is of course
and a great guy a great guy this is it
throwing in a shade but I assume he's
more of a cat lover than a dog lover
because we're sitting there and I'm
[ __ ] I'm heartbroken I'm devastated
right and I my [ __ ] my dog you know
what I mean so I want to talk to someone
I'm like yo Mike is that what's up
oh my [ __ ] dog down because okay it
sounds like him but the phone anyway
about three hours later were in the same
situation again just me and him sitting
there and it's still on my mind I'm
[ __ ] devastated and I'm thinking I
need to talk to someone maybe because of
my accident he didn't quite understand
me so I try it again yeah hey Mike
is that what am i hey guys yeah you told
me
all right all right yeah yeah I'll shut
the [ __ ] up then all right my bad
[Music]